[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing voldemort bellatrix lestrange
death eaters and horcruxes let's kick
things off with a brief intro on
horcruxes a horcrux is created when a
wizard takes an object and binds a piece
of their soul to it the purpose is
immortality with the logic going that as
long as a piece of your soul survives
within the object then you can never
truly die its magic so dark so heinous
that it was kept a secret from most of
the wizarding world
yet despite many trying there are only
two known wizards to have discovered how
to perform it an ancient greek dark
wizard called herpo the fowl who created
one horcrux and voldemort who mastered
the spell and created seven but what
i've always wondered is why didn't the
death eaters follow in voldemort's
footsteps and create horcruxes
themselves surely voldemort would have
entrusted someone like bellatrix with
the knowledge of how to create one
wouldn't he
dumbledore once described tom middle
school gang as a mixture of the weak
seeking protection the ambitious seeking
glory and the thugish seeking a leader
who could show the more refined cruelty
it was these same students that are
considered to be the forerunners to what
would become the death eaters that we
see later on in the books and films
death eaters are pure blood radical
supremacists that cast unforgivable
curses without remorse and torture
muggles half bloods and blood traitors
alike death eaters murder people
willy-nilly so it's not unreasonable to
expect that they would be willing to
murder to achieve immortality
furthermore the death eaters were
hell-bent on maintaining pure magical
bloodlines in the wizarding community
and one very effective way of doing that
would be to remain immortal as a
pureblood so is it just that the death
eaters were left in the dark by
voldemort unaware of what it was that he
had achieved or was it that the creation
of a horcrux was just too imposing after
all horcrux creation was even too dark
to be properly mentioned in a book about
the dark arts the falling poet from
voldemort suggests that at least some of
the death eaters knew something about
what he had done
and then i asked myself but how could
they have believed i would not rise
again
they who knew the steps i took long ago
to guard myself against mortal death he
says it right there who knew the steps i
took
surely this suggests that he had
educated them on porcruxes right
now the book never explicitly states
which death eaters knew but i'm sure he
didn't mention it to all of them and
there's one in particular that comes to
mind when i think of who he might have
told bellatrix lestrange and who better
to create one than bellatrix with the
know-how and the bloodthirsty capability
why wouldn't she make one bellatrix
lestrange was one of the most feared
witches in a wizarding world her fear
inspiring name and bloodthirsty
reputation were well deserved and she
was known to have murdered and tortured
many many witches and wizards her
magical capabilities were more than
impressive and she was widely considered
to be one of the most powerful and
dangerous witches of her time she was a
frightening pureblood that came from the
black family a long line of powerful
witches and wizards with a twisted
agenda more importantly however
belichick's lestrange was lord
voldemort's most loyal follower but to
add to that she certainly wasn't just a
follower we have to address the elephant
in the room here because i think it
helps to answer this question bellatrix
was obsessed with voldemort though she
served him unquestionably she always
wanted more she wanted to be his queen
and she wanted to rule over the magical
and muggle worlds alongside him so what
better way to ensure that they could
rule together forever than by making
herself immortal as well in an interview
jk rowling discusses the intensity of
bellatrix's infatuation with her master
and bellatrix was as i think is clear
you know i doubt that people will be
particularly shocked to hear because i'm
sure they've deduced that bellatrix is
madly romantically in love with
voldemort this is you know that's the
obsession of her life and whether you
want to accept it as canon or not we
know from the cursed child that
voldemort and bellatrix eventually
conceive a child delfini delfini's
conception occurred sometime in the mid
to late 1990s in secret at the malfoy
manor this meant that her birth
coincided with the events of the
original books we just never had any
vindication of it her birth was kept a
secret by her parents because they
feared that their infamous reputations
would place her in danger especially in
the event of their deaths how and why
bellatrix and voldemort would go on to
conceive a child is unknown though i
suspect that it was more of a functional
conception a way of voldemort carrying
on the bloodline of his ancestor salazar
slytherin this fact only strengthened
the tie between voldemort and bellatrix
further which makes the question even
more potent
why didn't bellatrix create a horcrux
here's what i think i think that
voldemort told some of his key followers
about horcruxes but i don't think that
he ever delved too much into these
specifics and i think that the reason
that he never delved into these
specifics wasn't to hide the process
from them but because he didn't believe
that they were strong enough to go
through with it creating a horcrux is
purportedly one of the most difficult
extreme and unknown magical processes
known in the western world if it was
hard going even for someone like
voldemort one of the most innately
powerful wizards of all time then how
can we reasonably expect that death
eaters would be successful i just don't
think that he had the faith in them to
go through with at all why would he
encourage and risk losing his followers
to a process that he knew they wouldn't
be able to handle jk rowling described
the process of creating horcruxes as
dangerous and highly inadvisable yeah
but i would imagine that other people
you know other people are going to have
tried i think it would be naive not to
think that people have been trying for a
long time and thought they succeeded and
hadn't or else or else you know made
themselves or killed themselves in the
attempt it's such a dangerous thing to
do to add to this voldemort though
incapable of love did care for bellatrix
why would he risk her life his genuine
concern for her life is depicted in the
following passage which describes
bellatrix's death bellatrix's gloating
smile froze her eyes seemed to bulge for
the tiny space of time she knew what had
happened and then she toppled and the
watching crowd roared and voldemort
screamed harry felt as though he turned
in slow motion he saw mcgonagall
kingsley and slughorn blasted backward
flailing and writhing through the air as
voldemort's fury at the fall of his last
best lieutenant exploded with the force
of a bomb voldemort raised his wand and
directed it at molly weasley and no he
wasn't just angry because he lost
another one of his soldiers he was
genuinely upset that bellatrix was gone
in fact i think that voldemort may have
even avoided the topic of horcruxes
specifically around bellatrix so that
she wouldn't get any funny ideas to
create one voldemort likely knew of
bellatrix's obsession with him and he
also knew that if he planted the idea of
her immortality in her head she would
have done anything in order to achieve
it had voldemort and the death eaters
won the wasting war and had bellatrix
survived i think that maybe just maybe
further down the line voldemort would
have introduced the idea of her creating
one in a controlled environment in this
way they would be able to take their
time and be extra careful as to minimize
any kind of risk anyway i think that
about sums it up did you guys ever
wonder this does my logic make sense
here if you enjoyed the content please
like the video subscribe to the channel
and leave a comment down below
until next time remember it is our
choices that show what we truly are far
more than our abilities
[Music]
you